de mourir en janvier dernier enquête à
diffuser les derniers moments de chantal
lavigne
depuis trois ans elle fréquentait un
groupe de croissance personnelle dirigé
par gabriel fréchette en juillet 2011
lors d'une activité de sudation dans une
pièce fermée
les participants ont été enduits de boue
enveloppés dans du plastique et de
nombreuses couvertures et ont eu la tête
recouverte d'une boîte de carton pendant
neuf heures chantal lavigne est morte
d'hyperthermie nous avons obtenu les
enregistrements sonores de cette séance
ces deux cas la mort est la liberté
la mort c'est la vérité la mort elle
retour à dieu
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gabriel fréchette a refusé toutes nos
demandes d'entrevue nous quelques jours
après la diffusion de notre reportage
en janvier elle a accordé deux entrevues
à la radio
l'apport l'être pendant un temps où il y
aurait eu négligence de la banque
elle atteindra depuis des années que
l'on l'effet d'un peu partout et à tous
les curieux de nature pression des
techniques de collage qui nous avons
traversée moi j'ai fait une formation
avec chaman druide en bretagne en 2000
moi j'ai plus ma formation avec un être
femme en bretagne fait patrick d'accueil
je démens formellement
nous avons retrouvé le chaman patrick da
kid dans sa campagne bretonne
il a collaboré à l'élaboration d'un code
d'éthique chamanique après une rencontre
avec l'organisation française de lutte
contre les dérives sectaires
il est furieux que gabriel fréchette
affirme qu'il l'ait formique pour faire
des sudation je n'ai jamais formé
personnes pour faire des de sudation
encore moins elle qui a pratiqué une de
sudation deux ou trois fois maximum
une citation ça dure la cérémonie en
elle-même va durer trois heures puis au
bout de 25 minutes on fait rentrer des
bouteilles d'eau chacun va boire pour
s'hydrater quoi il est question
d'enfermer des gens dans du plastique de
leur foule des paquets de couverture
dessus pour qu'ils cuisent et on leur
met une boîte de carton où ils respirent
de l'air carbonique
ce sont des principes mais inacceptable
jamais aucun chaman n'a pu faire une
chose pareille
c'était pendant neuf heures 9 heures ce
que je nous je ne reviens pas c'est
gates a eu plus de personnes de morte
parce que je ne sais pas comment un
corps humain peut supporter une telle
barbarie une telle torture
ça a duré combien votre formation avec
le chaman druide et de canards c'est fou
explique patrick d'acquis qui a
rencontré gabriel fréchette une première
fois il ya dix ans lors d'une conférence
à bordeaux il a passé une journée avec
moi et pendant une journée jeux
témoigner des pratiques celtique
elle a tellement été enchanté son groupe
a tellement été enchanté de ce qu'ils
avaient vu que j'étais invité l'année
d'après pour aller enseigner
les pratiques et celtique au québec j'y
suis allé quatre fois dans l'année
quatre fois ci joue je me sens humilié
je me sens confisqué je me sens presque
violée c'est à dire que on utilise mais
non pour des pratiques barbares en
novembre dernier muni d'une caméra
cachée
une collaboratrice est allé chez gabriel
fréchette dans le but d'obtenir un
rendez vous avec elle
gabriel fréchette donne des formations
depuis 20 ans et affirme que plus de
2000 personnes ont suivi ces
enseignements l offre et notre
collaboratrice de lui envoyer la liste
des cours offerts par son groupe elle en
offre des centaines mais se situent les
programmes retrouver sentait trop porte
web parce qu'on appelle et vous m et 10
kg
dès sa première rencontre avec gabriel
fréchette en 2007
chantal lavigne a cru qu'elle pourrait
gagner sa vie comme formatrice
nous avons obtenu les enregistrements de
cette séance et de gras se décrasser nos
clips sec tout une question
d'investissement et le choix de vous en
livrer à partir de l'instant où vous la
choisir
chantal lavigne a signé un contrat de
trois ans pour une valeur de près de 19
mille dollars
le principe qui suivit habituellement
par l'ensemble de ces gros plots ces
deux d'inscrire les gens dans des
scieries de cours siame casoni et
criminologue et spécialiste des groupes
de croissance personnelle en suivant
encore un autre court encore un autre
mais ils vont pouvoir donner devenir à
leur tour formateur et donc de formation
information très très souvent les gens
qui commet son premier cours vont
s'embarquer pour des séries parfois de
plusieurs années de dizaines et de
dizaines de courts dès sa deuxième
visite au québec patrick da qui a rompu
lié avec gabriel friche est il y avait
des degrés de l'initiation qui était
inventé tous les mois c'était une
manière à n'en plus finir de de
maintenir les gens sous dépendance
les balises actuellement qui est un
cadre ces groupes au québec n'ont ils
aucune balise ils ne sont pas
répertoriés nulle part en france après
les événements de l'ordre du temple
solaire un organisme de lutte contre les
dérives sectaires a été écrit miviludes
cet organisme relève directement du
premier ministre français la prévention
c'est connaître phénomène informer nos
concitoyens des dangers nous faisons
comment rapport annuel remis au promu
disque est très médiatisée un site
internet il est question qu'on nous pose
nous recevons à peu près 2000
interrogations par an nous répondons à
toutes les interrogations sur des
mouvements qui peuvent présenter des
dangers
georges fenech et le président de milieu
il explique que son organisation possède
des vrais moyens de fonctionnement
toutes les forces vives françaises tous
les pouvoirs publics sont rassemblés
dans la lutte contre les dérives
sectaires
par ce rachat représente une véritable
menace pour la démocratie et pour les
personnes de 1987 à 1993
le québec a eu un organisme à but non
lucratif qui répertoriait et qui donnait
de l'information sur les groupes de
croissance personnelle
il s'appelait info croissance c'est line
beauchamp l'actuel ministre de
l'éducation et vice premier ministre qui
était la directrice de l'organisme
premièrement renseigne à la fois les
consommateurs et les promoteurs sur
leurs responsabilités et sur leurs
droits et on un service de médiation en
cas de plainte
line beauchamp était à l'époque
convaincu de l'importance de son
organisme
lorsqu'on apprit la défend aujourd'hui
impossible de savoir ce qu'elle en pense
on me l a refusé de nous accorder une
entrevue sur ce sujet au québec il n'y a
actuellement aucune volonté d'injecter
des fonds pour créer un organisme
d'information et de prévention sur les
groupes de croissance personnelle c'est
la vérité un organisme qui serait
essentiel selon diane casoni ça permet
aussi aux gens qui sont intéressés par
un cours de croissance personnelle ou
qui ont un problème avec un cours donné
d'avoir informations nécessaires pour
savoir comment agir quels sont les
recours possibles et ce terrain
ok excusez moi j'entends des ports est
bien réel fréchette affirme ne plus
faire de hutte de sudation
mais il continue encore maintenant de
donner des formations à ses membres les
cas qui viennent vers moi c'est parce
que à quelques pas d'une philosophie les
abeilles en bout d'un an tan tan et qui
au bout d'athènes ce qui relève de moi
qui te n'est pas équilibré chef du
gouvernement chaque entraînement il
s'occupait alors il vient d'entendre ça
tombait n'a pas compensé tout ça
[Musique]